[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero Luis Méndez Luis economistas
del Banco Mundial alertan sobre un
posible riesgo de recesión para el
próximo año porque se podría presentar a
esta situación cuéntenos Andrés de
acuerdo con el informe emitido en el que
el Banco Mundial advierte que los
análisis responden a los economistas que
participaron en el estudio pero que no
corresponde a los puntos de vista de la
organización se señala que existen
factores que están presionando a las
economías para frenar su crecimiento por
lo que resta de 2022 y en gran parte
2023 el análisis se sustenta en que las
tres principales economías para el Banco
Mundial como lo son Estados Unidos China
y la zona Euro han presentado una
desaceleración drástica en los últimos
meses de hecho en este mes de enero el
fondo monetario internacional tenía una
estimación de crecimiento global de 4,4%
pero en julio cinco meses después de la
guerra dicha perspectiva se redujo a un
3,2%. pero sobre el riesgo de recesión
días atrás se pronun presidente del
Banco Central europeo Cristian lagard
en el punto de referencia no
pronosticamos un crecimiento negativo en
2023 en el escenario a la baja lo
hacemos
ese escenario difiere de la situación
actual que incluye en particular el
cierre total de todo el suministro de
gas rusos
para conocer más detalles de las causas
que propician esta desaceleración más
temprano conversamos con el economista
James Salazar Salinas y esto fue lo que
nos dijo Después de la de los
principales momentos de la de la o de
los peores momentos de la pandemia Pues
empieza una recuperación y a raíz de
ello empieza a dispararse ciertas
presiones inflacionarias estas sobre
todo se intensificaron en el 2021
inicialmente los bancos centrales
cometieron el error y la mayoría de los
analistas nos pasó de considerarlas como
temporales entonces para hacer frente a
este fenómeno por lo que se requiere es
lo inverso a lo que hiciste en la
pandemia tienes que empezar estímulos
entonces hay una sincronización en la
mayoría de los bancos centrales en el
mundo actualmente estaríamos hablando de
cerca de 90 bancos centrales que en los
últimos meses han estado subiendo la
tasa de interés esto que provoca a la
hora de subir tasas de interés lo que
buscas es incidir directamente en la
actividad económica para qué Para para
tratar de frenar las presiones
inflacionarias tienes niveles de
inflación muy alto el problema de frenar
la actividad económica o sea es que en
determinado momento esto se pueda
traducir en una recesión Luis y cómo
podría impactar esta situación en
América Latina Andrés recordemos que la
mayoría de las economías de la región
son exportadoras de materias primas
hacia las naciones industrializadas pero
veamos que nos dijo el economista James
Salazar al respecto
todas las regiones como bien comentas
empiezan a tener dudas y con con la
perspectiva de al menos una
ralentización de la actividad económica
y en el peor de los casos una recesión
Pues básicamente nos veríamos toda la
región afectadas A lo mejor dependiendo
del grado de caídas y si Estados Unidos
la duración de esta posible recesión es
más de dos trimestres a lo mejor México
Centroamérica serían los más los más
afectados también hay otro elemento
importante considerar que son la la
estructura de la economía sobre todo la
parte de las finanzas públicas o sea
quién A qué país toma mejor preparado Y
en este caso pues a la mejor a México lo
está mejor posicionado respecto a lo que
observamos por ejemplo en Colombia
Entonces en ese caso también vamos a ver
divergencia y diferencias en el grado de
de sensibilidad a este a este riesgo
económico Luis es que se ha hablado
muchísimo de la inflación Pero cómo
podrían actuar los gobiernos para
controlarla Andrés de acuerdo con la
comisión económica para América Latina y
el Caribe la inflación en la región
podría rondar el 8,1% para este año
cuando en el 2021 fue de 6,6%. El
economista James Salazar nos explica que
podrían hacer los gobiernos para lanzar
un programa que efectivamente la
controla
Hay pocas acciones que que tienen
impacto directo en el control de precios
o en el control de inflación y uno de
ellos es lo que están actuando que es la
política monetaria esto tiene que ser
contundente transparente y dar o tratar
de anticipar los futuros pasos para
buscar anclar las expectativas de
inflación eso es lo más relevante ahora
qué otras acciones pudieran determinado
momento llevar a cabo es políticas que
favorezcan la producción entonces
necesitamos que la producción aumente
entonces la mayoría de las políticas
deberían estar encaminadas a ellos a
incrementar la producción El problema es
que que este tema de inflación se
politiza Y entonces empezamos a ver
acciones como controles de precios eso
pueden tener impacto positivo quizás de
corto plazo Pero a medida en el largo
plazo Generalmente tienen implicaciones
mucho más costosas dice que nos trae
como cifra del día Andrés han sido 14
las recesiones que ha sufrido la
economía global la n 150 años la primera
de ellas 1876 cuando una grave crisis
financiera des una depresión en Europa y
América del Norte y duró hasta 1879 la
última de ellas fue en el año 2020
cuando hubo una caída de 6,2% y según
los especialistas fue la cuarta peor
entonces Muchas gracias por la
información económica